um but you wrote a phenomenal piece um
which
it resonated so deeply with me and i
don't do this often but when i see a
piece that's written by an expert
that gives actual practical advice
that's not some rehash
[ __ ] that i see all the time on
medium i immediately say hey can you
come on the podcast and can we just chop
it up
into pieces and walk people through it
step by step
and then the title of the piece is you
think you need a ceo a cheap
chief operating officer which you were
one of the elite ones here in silicon
valley
but what you say here in the headline is
what you really need
is an operating philosophy so i want to
get right into this with you
um so
i'm sure you have had this experience
i've had this experience
you're at the board meeting the startup
starts feeling like it's coming apart at
the seams
and it's it's basically chaos right i
think you use the word [ __ ] show in your
piece
the first sentence um so
somebody raises their hand and says we
need a co you're saying you don't need a
co what you need is an operating
philosophy so explain what the operating
philosophy we're talking about here is
that you explain and
if you type in you think you need a coo
what you really need is an operating
philosophy into google you'll find this
or it's in the show notes
right so the yeah the title of the piece
is the cadence and it's about how you
put your startup on an operating cadence
to reduce the sense of chaos and
um synchronize all of the efforts of the
employee
so that it's not you know a [ __ ] show
and this is
this um is specifically meant for
startups that are scaling from say 50
employees to 500 employees
um that's the the time period when this
really matters in the early days of a
startup
the biggest problem is not you know sort
of how to rain in the chaos it's just
how to find product market fit
um that's a separate blog post i wrote
you can check it out called wilderness
period uh but
this blog post the cadence is about how
you once you do find product market fit
how you how do you scale the company in
an elegant way
so that you can solidify the you know
the
the initial traction that you have and
um
you know and to scale this thing without
it degenerating into just
chaos and when you're under 30
people in my experience everybody's in
the same room
everybody's in the same you know earshot
of each other so
you haven't broken up into tribes you
haven't broken up into functions
uh as explicitly and even if you had you
know
you can kind of sit in on each other's
meetings once you get past 50 and you
got
20 people there's no conference room and
if you did have a conference big enough
it's chaos
correct so right so this is what happens
is that in the early days in the
beginning of a startup everybody is
in the same room either physically or
virtually you know in the days of covet
uh as a result everybody knows what
everybody else is doing everybody's
pretty much a generalist and the
founders
run around telling everybody what to do
and what to build
and that's the way the startup works in
that seed stage all the way to say
series a
but around 50 employees that approach
stops scaling
because there's just too many people in
the company for the founders to sort of
tell them what to do on a task level and
so you start
setting objectives uh you have to start
managing
teams and people and you start divvying
up the organization you start
breaking up the org chart into silos and
uh functional areas you've got a
you create a team for sales and customer
support and
and um you know obviously you know r d
engineering
um marketing and and then you also
hire your first product managers and so
you'll go from
the product road mapping dictated ad hoc
by the
sort of the founder ceo to uh you know
the founders have to work through
product managers to to guide the
development of the startup and
so this is sort of the fundamental
change as you get above
50 employees on your way to say 500.
and you know what what typically happens
is that because of this
these new functional silos in the
company it starts to feel very
compartmentalized
and and so people kind of feel
isolated or disconnected at the same
time you've got other functions which
are underdeveloped they may not have
mature leadership yet
they may not have any leadership yet and
so you've got other functions that
you know just aren't quite working and
the result of this
sort of disorganization and disconnect
is chaos
and so the cadence is designed to
describes my operating philosophy
that i started using at paypal as ceo
kind of figured it out there and then i
adapted it
for sas at yammer and it's sort of a
operating philosophy i think everybody
can use and it basically tells you how
to organize
the four major functions of a sas
startup and then how to
synchronize them